[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where my brother and I answer you
questions give your dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon and it feels like
forever since I last podcast did John
but there's so much news from AFC
Wimbledon so much news from AFC
Wimbledon Hank I am exhausted because as
I speak to you I have just gotten home
from our amazing trip to Wembley our dad
was there rosianna was there Meredith
who edits the Wimbley WOM please games
that we used to sponsor AFC Wimbledon
was there it was an amazing amazing day
at Wembley fifty-seven thousand people
in the stadium to watch Plymouth Argyle
take on AFC Wimbledon for a spot in the
third tier of English football AFC
Wimbledon with the smallest stadium in
the fourth tier of English football one
of the smallest playing budgets it was
just an amazing day Hank 22,000 AFC
Wimbledon fans were there they were
wearing dftba on the back of their
shorts at England's national stadium
after a tense scoreless first half in
the second half 15 minutes in Lisle
Taylor that man who Eyal Taylor the
Messi for Montserrat the Montserrat
international just got enough of a touch
on a cross to send it into the back of
the net and as it you know as the ball
like rippled in the back of the net I
thought to myself he wasn't offside and
the ball is in the net so that means
that Wimbledon have scored and all
around me everyone was celebrating and I
was just thinking but how is this
possible how did this happen yes there
must be something wrong I had done such
a good job of explaining to myself over
and over again that just getting to
Wembley was an incredible accomplishment
for this team it never really crossed my
mind that they might win and then in the
96th minute there was an astonishing
amount of extra time in the game Hank
audible walk and phenoix scored a
penalty to ensure that AFC Wimbledon
were going to Ligue 1
they won the game the team that just not
too long ago had like a 5% chance of
having a 25% chance of being a third
tier English football team suddenly and
unexpectedly has a 100% chance of having
a 100% chance of being a third tier
English soccer team Hank we sponsor a
third tier English soccer team our
community has now watched AFC Wimbledon
get promoted it's their sixth promotion
since the club was reformed in 2002 it's
just an incredible story
I'm so grateful to everybody I went back
to King's meadow after the game Hank and
I want to say thanks to the AFC
Wimbledon supporters who sang my name
nothing has ever made me happier but I
gotta also say all the players went out
and hung out with the fans after the
game because they understand that it is
the fans who own this team and it was an
amazing thing to hang out with the
captain Barry Fuller oughta buy a lock
and phenoix it was just it was amazing
it was just what it what a crazy day I'm
so glad that I went I'm sorry you
weren't there but it was it was
wonderful I assume that there is more
news from AFC Wimbledon to come later
because you just I feel like you just
gave all the news from AFC Wimbledon
already oh no no no that's just the
beginning of the the news from AFC will
get the end of the yes happy and how are
you I'm sorry you're just back from tour
how was tour tour was great I am so
happy that I did it and we saw so many
dear Hank and John listeners people were
very excited every time I mentioned the
podcast on stage they are big fans of
the pot John we got we got the this is a
this is a thing and people love it and
I'm so happy I'm so happy that you like
it you people of the world share it with
all your friends I also met many fans of
the pod when I was at Wembley people
kept coming up to me and saying they
enjoyed the podcast and it was great it
was so fun thanks to everybody who
listens and thanks to everybody who
supports us on patreon we don't like to
talk about how this podcast is properly
sponsored but it is sponsored in truth
by our viewers so thanks to all of you I
hope you enjoy the monthly Google
Hangouts that we do but also we just
want to say that we really
appreciate you supporting the podcast
but thanks to everybody who listens and
also you can head over to the patreon if
you want for things like pictures of
Tuggle the cookie jar that turns out
Hank did not destroy I did not destroy
thanks also to mom for being on the pod
John do you have a short poem for us I
do have a short poem Hank it's uh now
let know charitable hope by Eleanor
Morton Wiley an American poet from the
sort of late 19th early 20th century now
that no charitable hope confuse my mind
with images of eagle and of antelope I
am by nature none of these I was being
human born alone I am being woman hard
beset I lived by squeezing from a stone
what little nourishment I get in masks
outrageous and austere the years go by
in single file but none has merited my
fear and none has quite escaped my smile
Eleanor Morton wily with now let no
charitable hope I love that idea that no
year has quite merited her fear and none
has quite escaped her smile there's a
little bit of Hope in that poem and I'm
just feeling very hopeful right now
because I have been reminded that
occasionally improbable wonders do
befall us all right well thank
congratulations on having an improbable
wonder befall you John just put that on
a t-shirt and it'll be all right let's
get to some questions from our listeners
ok I've got one this one is from Riley
who asks dear Hank and John I'm a
graduate student studying agricultural
chemistry and earlier today I was
delighted to find out that I got a grant
which will allow me to do a study about
greenhouse gas emissions from manure
shortly after I was walking across the
quad when a bird defecated right onto my
head according to the internet a bird
pooping on your head is considered good
luck now I am not generally
superstitious but considering the poopy
coincidence can't I interpret this as a
good omen for my research to come or am
I just trying to make the best out of a
crappy situation thanks for the question
Riley Riley I appreciate your pun no it
is not good luck to have a bird
upon you in my opinion says you know I
don't think it's good well I well its
first I think maybe it's good luck but
the bird was just a late hmm interesting
good luck it was retroactive with regard
to the grant that was already given but
then additionally I think that
pretending like bad things happening to
you bad things that you cannot control
and that art are not caused by anything
but mere coincidence like just bird poop
it's good to imagine that they're good
even since they are objectively bad but
you can't avoid them it's a thing that's
going to happen sometimes yeah I guess I
just don't want to become too dependent
on like looking to the heavens for omens
because I think that's a bit of a
dangerous business because you then you
start to see bad ones and that becomes a
kind of self-defeating thing so I try to
avoid that but I don't always succeed
also if you're looking to the heavens
for omens yes like literally you might
get pooped in the eye yeah that's bad it
you got to make sure that you keep your
head level so that the poop falls on you
no more pervy more impervious surface I
got pooped on recently by a bird I was
having coffee and it pooped right on my
hand in the in the hand I was holding my
coffee in but not in the coffee and I
felt like that was I feel like that was
a nice coincidence that it was just on
my hand and not in my coffee
so in summary our advice in this
situation Riley is under no
circumstances should you ever look at
the sky you should just assume that it
is up there yeah but never look at it
because there is a small chance but a
very real chance that a bird will poop
into your eye and that would be bad luck
bad luck sky poop sky poop is bad ok we
have another question this one comes
from Cass who writes dear brothers green
good try Cass but no she writes Dear
John and Hank my girlfriend and I have a
long debate going and we're going to
need you to clear something up what is
the best way to eat an Oreo I am a fan
of dunking it in milk roughly halfway
letting it sit for a couple of seconds
then eating the cookie and when I've had
my fill then drinking the milk she
thinks that you have to drop the cookie
into the cup of milk let it sit at the
bottom and drink the milk until you find
your soggy or
you okay Cass Hank I think we can agree
that neither of these ways is the best
way to eat and I throw my pen on the
ground and distaste and we can say what
we can say is that there is no wrong way
to eat an Oreo unless all Oreos are bad
I don't know maybe they are they're not
great for you but I don't think they're
like high in vitamin A or anything but I
would argue is no wrong way to eat an
Oreo you and your girlfriend should
probably stop fighting about this etc
etc but in fact can I tell you the way
that I eat an Oreo yes please what I do
is I dip it about half way in water
which is exactly like dipping it in milk
but without any of the gross nosov milk
why are you making that noise because I
hate you why that's oh I thought there
was no wrong way to eat an Oreo okay
John there's no wrong way to eat an Oreo
next time you just dip it in some
hydrogen sulfide nothing wrong with
dipping your Oreo in water it gives you
all the moisture that milk does without
any of the gross milk Ness okay well
what I'm just gonna have a final say on
Oreos here I'm gonna ignore you
completely and say that the wonderful
thing about Oreos is that there are many
different ways to enjoy them you can
break them open and lick the cream out
you can dunk you can not dunk in all of
the ways have their own benefits and
that's the thing that I like about Oreos
and the reason why I don't allow them in
my house because I will eat the whole
package in one or two days because I
have no self-control
yeah I'm in the same boat actually I
have to be very careful about what I
bring into my home because I will yeah
oh yeah oh yeah so I I have not
purchased an Oreo in a decade maybe but
I do eat them whenever I'm at a friend's
house and they have them yeah I love to
dunk a good Oreo in water when I'm at a
friend's house as well let's ask another
question Hank this one comes
Thanh Mei in India who has a fantastic
question she writes dear John and Hank
i saw Hanks myspace profile myspace.com
/wh green and observed that John was not
on Hanks top eight why is that
this apparently the episode of dear Hank
and John where Hank stops communicating
in traditional English words and only
uses sounds I'm looking I'm looking at
my oh here's my top eight oh wow I just
clicked on something and I saw a human
but damn welcome to the new myspace I'm
looking at my top eight right now and
these are all real friends of mine yeah
your wife's there that person who is
that I don't know who that is I
remembered that person's name but anyway
yes my wife is there and a bunch of
friends and also the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge so I was more of a
friend with a Wildlife Refuge than I was
with you well yeah I mean I guess the
answer to that question is that back
when Hank and I last updated our
MySpace's which for me was I think in
2006 back then we were not as close as
we are now so I probably wasn't one of
Hanks top eight friends Hank do you
remember that song by Molly Lewis about
myspace mm-hmm I hope that you forget
about your myspace I hope it slips
completely from your ond and I hope it
stays up long enough for the next
generation to find yeah that one that
song has become so hilariously prophetic
we have all forgotten about our
MySpace's in fact we have lots of young
listeners who right now are asking
themselves what is a myspace a myspace
is what a Facebook was before regular
ngon college and high school students
could access Facebook and MySpace was a
huge huge deal and now it has become a
sort of strange library
of a
Eric and life in the years 2004 to 2006
well I mean it's changed so much that it
doesn't really look like what it used to
look like at all I have like seven
pictures on my myspace four of them are
just of me and one of them is of Kathryn
and there's like three people in my
myspace pictures who are not me that's
weird
yeah I know it has changed a lot but it
is it does still serve as a as a kind of
library I'm actually looking at my
myspace now and I must have updated it
in 2007 at the latest poco has a copy of
Paper Towns on it but yeah most of my
pictures are there some from my
honeymoon there's one of page rail
stones so I guess we used it during the
vlogbrothers era and then there's my
first author photo and a picture of me
feeding an iguana on my honeymoon so it
was in that era when I was you know
going on honeymoons which does seem to
be to me in the distant distant past all
right well I have now on the Arctic
National Wildlife Refuge is my space so
we're going to have to move on to the
next question
lest we spend the entire the entire
otherwise we're gonna fall all the way
down a rabbit hole yeah I agree so here
is another question this one's from
Lizzie who asks dear Hank and John it
shouldn't gravy boats be called gravy
baths as the gravy inside of it I like
that we're really focusing on the
hard-hitting difficult questions today
Hank will get there I think we'll get to
harder ones I have I have strong
opinions on this if I do have a strong
opinion but I suspect that your strong
opinion is that gravy boat is the wrong
word and we should start using gravy
baths whereas I actually really like
gravy boat I I also I agree with you I
agree with you because gravy boats are
the gravy is the passenger in the gravy
boat that's right it is sailing in the
ocean of Thanksgiving dinner that's
right so it is it is a sail on the ship
of your dining room table and the gravy
is the passage yes the the the water in
this in this metaphor is just the
ethereal nature of the feast that you
are that you are consuming
that's beautiful Hank just that this
sort of yes I things are like other
mister calling by not being a poet
things are like other things is one of
the best poems I've ever heard in my
entire life it's it's a simile but it's
also a metaphor it's got a lot going for
it I actually think I might get a things
or like other things tattoo someday I
have to say that I stole that joke from
Twitter and I don't know who Twiggy who
tweeted it I just saw it on tumblr and
it the tweet was yes we get it poets
things are like other things uh-huh God
that you acknowledge having stolen that
joke which I mean it's it would have
been perfectly plausible to me that two
people thought of that same joke but I
appreciate your honesty alright so I
feel like you want a more difficult
question John if you have well yeah I
have I have real questions here here oh
that's a real question the gravy boat
versus gravy bath issue but I think
let's try can we delve deeper into the
human experience is my question alright
yes this question is from Eva who asks
dear Hank and John I have a chronic
illness arthritis and I have great meds
from some my symptoms are under control
but I still go to the doctor twice a
year to keep track of it I was 13 when I
was diagnosed which meant that my
parents came to the doctor with me so a
few days before my appointment this week
I was reminding my dad of the visit and
my sister was surprised that I wanted
him there since I'm 18 now is that weird
is there an age at when which you should
go to the doctor alone my dad still
handles my prescriptions cuz it's
complicated and there's money involved
but in addition to that I like having
him there he's a smart guy
at which point am I expected to go to
the doctor by myself well I think this
is another thing where adulthood is a
process not an event or if there are
events in it they sort of only appear to
you in retrospect but I definitely don't
think you need to stop having your dad
go to the doctor with you the day you
turn 18 if you find it useful for him to
be there yeah I think that it is AI
think that there is a number a large
amount of information transfer all that
continues from parents to children
forever and and and having that be
having like creating systems for that to
happen is great and your doctor your dad
has been to the doctor more times than
you
and it knows how that works and it's
often good to have two sets of ears in a
doctor's office so that you remember
things more better and if you don't have
that then it's always also good to maybe
take a piece of paper and a pen or take
notes but yeah I yeah I think that there
will be a time when you will head out
and be doing that sort of thing on your
own and getting comfortable with that is
part of life yeah but there's no there's
no particular hurry no you know I hear a
lot about how adolescence is like being
extended and people aren't you know
diving headfirst into adulthood the way
that they used to or whatever and I
think that is a big load of hooey we
have always had a kind of slow process
through which adults become adults it
has never been instantaneous it has
never been the day of your Bar Mitzvah
or the day you turn 18 or any of that
and I think that I totally agree with
you that there is this you know
transferral between children and their
parents that should last as long as it
can last because I think it's very
useful absolutely that said at this
point I don't think that I'd want my dad
going to the doctor with me no not
unless it was although depends on which
know if it was something that like that
I hadn't gone through before but dad had
like you know like our dad had cancer
and if I had cancer I might be like hey
I wouldn't mind having my dad there
since he's been through this before
maybe like maybe that would be a useful
thing to have all right Hank here's
another question this one comes from
Andrea who asks Dear John and Hank I
recently graduated from college with my
bachelor's in education and I got a job
as a lead teacher at a headstart Center
I love my job my kids and the mission of
the program but sometimes I find my
family asking when I am going to get a
job at a quote real school it's true the
pay isn't as great as it would be at a
public or private school but I'm single
and I can afford my lifestyle so far and
plus there are more things involved than
just money
how can I stay affirmed in my choice of
career and tune out those people in my
life who don't think of preschool
teachers as real teachers
well Andrea I have to preschool age
children and let me tell you that in my
opinion their teachers are real teachers
who will have a long impact on their
lives and the idea that people who teach
five year olds or four year olds are
doing less important work than people
who teach six-year-olds strikes me as
frankly ludicrous yes I agree and I've
been thinking a lot about the way that
we decide culturally what jobs are
valuable and not valuable and by
extension what lives are valuable and
not valuable and the more I think about
it the more it angers me because it
seems it seems often like the the jobs
that we that we praise the least are the
ones that have the most impact on
individual people and the ones that we
praise the most are the ones that have
like small impacts on a large numbers of
people but I think that like the work
that we do to care for each other is the
most vital and most human work that we
do and I think that like but but but
figuring out how to like internalize
that in a world where you know maybe
you're getting signals that that isn't
the case is difficult so I just want to
say that you are doing great work and
internalizing that is a process but the
more you do it the better the more you
you know know that you are doing a great
job
you are being the best that you can be
at the job that the work that you're
doing and and the people that you care
for and the parents are the people that
you care for will be the beneficiaries
of you being great at what you're doing
and you are great and thank you yeah it
can be difficult to do that without
outside affirmation and unfortunately
the main way that people assign value to
work is the salary or hourly pay of that
work which I totally agree with you Hank
is a huge mistake because there are lots
of impacts that you can have on people's
lives that are not well measured by the
free market and especially with someone
like
who says that she feels like she's able
to afford her lifestyle in the work that
she does you know then the work itself
needs you know needs to be as valuable
to her as possible and I think that
taking care of kids and helping them
learn and getting them excited about the
world around them is incredibly
important work all right John I've got
another question if you're ready for
that
I'm ready bring it Madison asks
important question here dear Hank and
John I've lived my 22.5 years believing
that farts are completely harmless this
was until my partner called an
exceptionally audible and fragrant fart
of mine an air poop and it got me
thinking mm-hmm how much should I worry
about aerosolized fecal matter impacting
our health is there a limit I should be
aware of or is my partner just absurd I
feel ridiculous asking this as I'm a
college graduate and I feel as though I
should know better well I am NOT a
scientist but I am someone who is deeply
afraid of fecal contamination and and
even so I do not think you should worry
about this quote-unquote air poop
because in all likelihood you have two
layers between you and the air poop your
underwear oh god whatever shorts you are
wearing what if you're in the bath well
then you have you have a water
protective layer that's why I don't take
showers you need the water barrier Hank
everybody knows that well John I have a
question for you yes do you do you think
there's ever been a room in human
history that contained enough fart to be
dangerous probably not I just think that
this is a you know what just occurred to
me Hank yeah it's true that we talk
about death a lot on this body but we
might talk about poop more it's possible
we haven't talked about death a single
time this episode and poop has come up
at least twice yeah I've been thinking
about it death I mean but also poop
they're not totally unrelated you know
the dead bodies can poop great that's
great thank you for them
I'm feel that my life has gotten better
for knowing that back back in the
beginning of the space the space program
they worried that humans would create
enough hydrogen and methane to sort of
increase the likelihood of there being
fires in space missions but that turned
out to not be too much of a concern you
know there are so there are toxic
compounds in our poop methane
is somewhat toxic but not nearly as
toxic as hydrogen sulfide which is also
in our poop our poop our farts and in
their poop but hydrogen sulfide is very
dangerous compound even in very low
quantities we can smell it very easily
which is why if you smell a fart that
smells really rotten egg II that means
there's probably a small amount of
hydrogen sulfide in there but we don't
it it would be impossible to have enough
hydrogen sulfide in a fart to cause a
toxic reaction without you just running
as fast as you can away which does make
me a little concerned about astronauts
because there's nowhere you can run to
and they do have to have air scrubbers
to to purify the air and to sort of
always be circulating new air into the
end of the space station because it can
get stinky in there but it would be way
more stinky it would be wait it would be
it would be before it got dangerous it
would be so stinky that anybody would
just would run away anyway
but you should you don't have to worry
about like the traditional dangers of
poop which is the bacteria which are way
too large to be aerosolized and now you
know and knowing is half the battle
John I'm really proud of myself for
having talked this long about poop farts
err poop I mean you just you just kept
going you're clearly trying to make this
another episode of the podcast where you
talk more than I do Madison long story
short you have nothing to worry about
your partner is totally wrong about air
poop let's move on to another question
this one is from Alice who writes Dear
John and Hank I've been watching
vlogbrothers since I was in Middle
School and I'm now finishing my second
year at UC San Diego Wow
thank you for sticking with us all those
years Alice
I want to get some dubious advice about
decreasing worldsuck I'm a global health
major and I often struggle with how to
make an impact when I feel like I'm
unequipped to be useful to people in
need how do you recommend approaching
helping in a way that is respectful and
actually useful and also how do you pick
one problem in health or in other fields
to work on when it seems there are so
many ways to improve the world at so
many levels and in so many disciplines I
think that's a great question Hank and
the first thing that I would say and
this is a mistake that I feel like many
of us make in the rich world that we've
been making for a long time when it
comes to addressing poverty and global
health which is that I think it's
incredibly important to listen to listen
to what people you know people living in
poor communities know much much more
about the health problems and their
communities than we do and when we come
in and try to establish our ideas about
health and our solutions a lot of times
that becomes either ineffective or
counterproductive yeah and John knows a
lot more about this sort of thing that I
than I do the other thing I'd say is
when you're trying to pick
I feel like picking things can be very
difficult when you're trying to decide
what kind of work you're gonna do and
you have a lot of options sometimes the
best thing is just to pick you're doing
good work no matter what and I find that
often times it can it can be a little
paralyzing to have too many choices and
I solve that problem by not choosing and
basically doing a mental dart throw yeah
I don't think it's a bad idea actually I
I also find like multiple choices to be
very overwhelming
so listen to people around you the
problems that they find interesting the
problems that they think are solvable or
and then I think listen to people in the
communities you want to help about what
they think their biggest problems are
and go from there
but I am also out but I do agree that in
general it's good to just
kind of get started and then you learn
as you go along and you go down many
wrong paths and you have many wrong
directions but at least you're on the
path you know absolutely we have another
question this is from PUC from the
Netherlands dear Hank and John my sister
just sent me an adorable dftba french
llama toy thingy
but I've only been a nerdfighter for
about a year so my question is where did
this French llama come from I tried
looking for the video where you
explained it but y'all have made too
many videos this is a positive thing I
love your videos so can you please
explain the story of the llama before me
and my sister buy them thank you you are
great
thanks for giving us an opportunity to
talk about our new llama toy [ __ ] you
know how to ensure that your question
gets on the podcast our no law matter is
available now at dftba.com along with
lots of dear Hank and John merchandise
and other things activewear bobbleheads
lots of stuff lots of stuff this episode
is also brought to you by air poop
whether it's coming from the butt of a
bird and falling into your eyeball
because you were looking to the sky for
omens or flying out of your butt at
maximum speed err poop always there to
be good luck maybe feel like I did a
really good job with that one John isn't
bad today's podcast is also brought to
you by water water an unappreciated
accompaniment to food the day's bad gas
has additionally brought to you by your
top eight on myspace to check it before
your racket that's terrible I don't that
isn't funny and it didn't make any sense
although I guess if it isn't funny why
am i laughing and and by it I mean your
relationship with your brother who is
not on your top eat on my still isn't
funny but I'm still laughing
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by death death it hasn't been
mentioned on today's podcast so I
thought I should squeeze it in here uh
yes death of course do we want to give
back to the llama question because we
got a little distracted John yes so the
story of French the
I it's so complicated that I can't even
really tell it maybe Hank can tell it
but I don't really remember it it was
invented by Kristen who is a longtime
nerdfighter during the project for
awesome in either 2007 or 2008 and
basically it is an exclamation of joy
like French the llama AFC Wimbledon are
a third tier English football team would
be an example of how to use French the
llama and over the years I have been
trying to make it into a thing like
making it into an expression that lots
of people use the way that the character
that one character did with fetch in the
movie Mean Girls and just like fetch it
hasn't happened yet but I still believe
that it might happen still working on it
yeah a problem with French the llama is
that its internet shortening FTL already
has several different meanings including
for the lose which is the opposite of
for the win and faster-than-light which
is more of a science fiction
abbreviation than a internet one but but
I am supportive of John's quest even if
I don't personally share it mm-hmm I
appreciate that so yeah you can go to
dftba.com get lots of good things
including those llama toys if you are
interested Hank let's answer a couple
more questions before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon this question comes from Kate
who writes Dear John and Hank my mother
is interesting I love to follow the
rules like one day about two years ago
we were on a vacation up in the
mountains of North Carolina and we came
across an abandoned theme park of
Dorothy and The Wizard of Oz there was a
fence around it and on the gate a no
trespassing sign so of course I wanted
to fall with us but my mother insisted
we break in and see what it was like it
ended up being a very fond memory my
question is do you think it was wrong
that we broke in I still feel guilty
over it but the gate wasn't even locked
and other people were wandering around
the abandoned park Hank what do you
think on this one I am delighted that
that this is this is the interaction
that the mother
is like let's break some rules and the
child is like we must follow the rules
it used to be the opposite I feel like I
I think that it's fine to break the
rules sometimes especially if the gate
isn't locked then maybe you're putting
up the no trespassing sign purely as a
way to you know eliminate any liability
to say we said don't go in and they went
in and then they got hit by a thing that
fell out of a tree but bird poop may may
have just been bird poop very dangerous
bird poop I is if it gets in your eye I
I think it's great I I it sounds fun to
me I did just recently you know enter a
no trespassing area for for the purposes
of urban exploring myself and I know
that you have done that as well John
yeah where did you go it was not so much
urban exploring as as abandoned office
park in the desert exploring mmm it's
called the domes in Arizona and it was
this this incompleted like a weird
office building that some tech company
tried to create but then it never got
moved into and now it's just these weird
space like structures that are very cool
and off the highway and I really enjoyed
visiting them you can see a little bit
of it in my second two most recent
vlogbrothers video yeah I I also enjoy
urban exploring although I am somewhat
troubled by the ethics of it and tried
to remain on the right side of the
ethics of it whenever possible I did
break into an abandoned theme park in
Germany once and it was awesome so great
wasn't really breaking and it was a
similar situation where I just opened an
unlocked gate but it was very very cool
and I ended up making the 999th log
brothers video there so we're probably
the wrong people to consult on this
particular topic because we're probably
more like your mom but in any case I
just don't think that you should feel
guilty about it I think you've just got
to let it go and enjoy the fond part of
the memories and then you know the next
time you have a chance to break into an
abandoned theme park you'll have to make
that decision to new yeah I don't know
like John and I have I think different
perspectives on
rule-breaking I generally tend to think
it's okay as long as you're not hurting
anybody or yourself well mmm I mean I
like I like rules there yeah there's a
certain like like like societal
structure that giving sanctity to the
rules yeah it's and and and that that is
a sort of greater good yeah and that's
sort of John I feel like that's your
perspective yeah yeah yeah I'm in favor
of preserving the rule of law and I
think paying attention to the rules does
that even when the rules are maybe not
the best rules that said there are
obviously rules that need to change and
you know civil disobedience breaking
those rules on purpose is a very
important strategy for changing them so
I don't want to you know it's do away
with all rule breaking I just think in
general I do I am very fond of structure
and order yes SEZ SEZ the person who is
uh who's benefitted greatly from the
current structure and order no
admittedly but I was more thinking about
just like personally like people with
people with OCD tend to have or create
very structured lives I wasn't thinking
about like the the larger systems of
structure which are in many cases
profoundly unjust and I do try to be
aware of that hey let's get to one more
question all right this one's from Phil
who asks dear Hank and John about a year
ago I opened my kitchen drawer to take
out the can opener and to open a can of
soup but what I held it in my hand to
open the can it felt all wrong I looked
at it questioningly and while it
superficially looked like the same can
opener there were elements of it that I
didn't recognize the handle was slightly
of the wrong shape the weight was a
couple of ounces off and it was more
stiff to use I mentioned this to my wife
and she maintains that it is the same
can opener we've always had I love my
wife and I trust her not to lie to me
about the existential state of our
kitchen implements but is it more likely
that she bought a new can opener and
didn't tell me or that I am now not
residing in the same universe as the can
opener I have used for much of my adult
life how can I tell
Phil Phil I'm gonna tell you the God's
honest truth about this you have to let
it go if you don't let it go it will
take over your life it will become the
consuming question of your life and on
your deathbed you will look up at
whomever you are dying in the presence
of which will likely not be your wife
because she will have left you because
this thing is going to become so
consuming in your life and you will say
it wasn't the same
can opener and then you will be just as
dead as you would always have been is it
possible that you live in a multiverse
that was like twisted around this one
particular can opener yes is it likely
yes but you have to let it go or it's
going to consume you oh man I just I I
want to know what relationship Phil has
with his wife that he's like but you're
lying why would she I trust my spouse
but she has been known to lie about
replacing kitchen
I do trust her very much but III think
someone broke into your house and
swapped out can openers yeah I think
it's totally possible that you had
that's maybe what you should just decide
happened just for your own just for your
own ability to navigate the universe as
if it were a static thing you need to
decide that somebody broke into your
house switched out the can openers to
freak you out and that's the way it went
down
I had a related thing happened to me
once Hank where I went out into the
parking lot of my apartment building in
Chicago and my car wasn't there and so I
called the police as you do when your
car has been stolen and the police
called me back and they said your car is
half a block away you just forgot where
you left it this happens all the time I
was like no no I didn't I parked in the
parking lot I am quite positive there's
no reason why I wouldn't have parked in
the parking lot but there indeed was my
car half a block away and
I have well obviously I haven't let it
go but I've been trying to let it go for
the last 15 years because the other
possibilities are all unacceptable I'm
going to tell you just a little story
before we get to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon which is related I once
had my bike stolen and I was frustrated
and you know they got a new bike and
just dealt with it and and I didn't even
call the cops because it wasn't a nice
bike or anything and then later downtown
I saw my bike locked to a bike rack with
my lock Wow
and I unlocked it using my code and
biked it away because indeed my bike had
not been stolen I had just forgotten
that I left it or or that is the moment
that you disconnected from the universe
that you had always known up until that
moment one of those two things happened
possibly one of those two things happens
before we get any further down this
rabbit hole I'm gonna need to move on to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
Hague what is the news from Mars
well John as you may remember back in
early to the podcast we tried to figure
out how much it would cost to get AFC
Wimbledon and the competing team let's
just say Stevenage to Mars
so just kidding we don't play Stevenage
next season all right
then one of the other sports teams to
Mars to play a game on the surface of
Mars now taking out of consideration the
fact that you would need to build an
airtight Stadium and food and everything
we did some calculations tried to figure
it out we no longer have to do those
calculations John because SpaceX has
just released a deal a term sheet
basically just a cost like basically
like just like just a you know a list of
costs that tell you how much it costs to
send things to places and you can send
things to Mars for as little as sixty
two million dollars all you have to do
is give sixty-two million dollars to
SpaceX and they can send up to eight
thousand eight hundred
the pounds of stuff to Mars if you want
to send up to 29,000 pounds of stuff to
Mars that will only cost you ninety
million dollars it's a bargain bargain
rate that that requires the Falcon heavy
rocket instead of the Falcon 9 rocket
and yeah so I think with with 29,000
pounds 30 tons of stuff we could
definitely get two football teams to
Mars and that's a mere 90 million
dollars John that's all well it's very
rare that I get to correct you about
something but 29,000 pounds is not 30
tons oh yeah you're right it's true
though we could get two teams with
14,000 with with 14.5 tonnes I'm pretty
sure that we could get two teams to Mars
unless they were all composed of
auto-buy oh I can fend WA then
unfortunately it would be impossible yes
the craziest moment of the League Two
play-off final was Aachen Fenwick came
on in about the 75th minute he just
causes so many problems for teams that
are trying to figure out how to defend
him and there was this crazy moment
right at the beginning of stoppage time
where Aachen phenoix was just standing
still and some and he was about to the
ball was passed to him and so someone
ran toward him in an attempt to win the
ball they ran into Aachen phenoix and
they were knocked unconscious
Aachen Fenn would didn't do anything
like he just all he did was stand and he
was called for a foul and he was like
what did I do and then he looked down
and he was like oh well that's
unfortunate but all I did was stand and
like a stretcher had to come on and
stretch her off this poor soul from
Plymouth who'd made the terrible mistake
of running into a space currently
occupied by autobuyer can phenoix it was
just it was an amazing moment and it
brings me to the news from AFC Wimbledon
very very sad news Hank there's the the
immensely good news that Wimbledon in a
stunning turn of events are going from
having the smallest Stadium in Ligue 2
to having the smallest Stadium in Ligue
1 but along the way three players have
been released by AFC Wimbledon
and this is a weird thing that happens
in football in fact like in the in the
interview immediately after the game
Otto Baraka and phenoix hilariously and
beautifully said I'm going to be
released tomorrow so any managers who
are interested in my services please hit
me up on what sack he's amazing he
hugged the manager Neal Ardley and said
can you believe this guy is releasing me
um
but it's true AFC Wimbledon will be
playing in the third tier without the
services of auto bio a convener
Callum Kennedy who's been immense for
Wimbledon which also was also released
it which is difficult you know it's a
difficult thing it happens after every
season I guess but it just makes me I
make you know it's it's it's it's sad in
the wake of something like this that
said also Sean rig has been released as
well that said you know they do this as
quickly after the end of the season as
possible to give those people hopefully
plenty of time to find jobs and I know
that I will follow all three of those
players but especially Aachen phenoix
wherever they go from here because
they've just been such an important part
of this amazing AFC Wimbledon season and
a-knockin fen was case I mean really you
know I don't think that Wimbledon would
have been promoted without him so he's
an amazing player but he's moving on to
other opportunities why did they release
him I don't understand how well because
he is he's mostly played as a substitute
and I think you know he's at a point in
his career where he wants to be playing
for four full games and you know the
Lyle Taylor and Tom Elliot are have just
been you know sort of preferred by the
manager over the last season and a half
so I think you know it's probably the
right thing for him as well but it's
just it's inherently difficult it's just
part of it's part of soccer I guess but
I mean that guy is gonna be a legend at
Wimbledon for as long as people are
singing songs
AFC Wimbledon they'll be singing about
Aachen phenoix so that's the news but
the good news is that we are not playing
Stevenage next season instead we're
playing teams like Bolton Wanderers
Swindon Town Swim and of course most
astonishingly the franchise currently
playing in Milton Keynes Hank the team
that o that moved to Milton Keynes will
be playing AFC Wimbledon they'll be in
the same league next season match which
I think says everything that needs to be
said about whether it was in the wider
interests of football to have a team in
Wimbledon the English FA in 2002 said
that it wasn't in 2017 I think we will
be able to agree that it was alright
John we have a couple of quick comments
from people many people had comments
about floppy disks Sophie said that her
dad works at a newspaper when the FBI
gives them data they give it to them on
floppy disks and Jenna also works at a
law firm in New Zealand and says that
businesspeople sometimes prefer floppy
disks because they're less likely to get
malware on them and Martino has a
brother who once showed a middle school
middle school students a floppy disk and
they thought that he had 3d printed a
Save icon also Alex writes Dear John and
Hank my name is Ryan in the most recent
podcast Hank said this episode is
brought to you by floppy disks you may
want to know that your 54.6 9 megabyte
podcast would be brought to you by 38
3.5 oh man I remember those days when
you used to have to have like seven
floppy disks to play one one game of
King's Quest or whatever I remember it
as well thank you for for joining me in
this podcast John what did we learn
today well we learned never to look at
the sky no matter what the circumstances
we learned that gravy boat saw sail on
the ocean of your dining room table we
learned to delete your old social media
profiles quickly before you forget the
password and we learned that preschool
teachers are awesome how we already knew
that but I guess we re learned it all
right
oh thank you everybody for listening to
this episode of dear Hank and John it's
a pleasure as always to have you
listening to our dumb voices if you want
to support our podcast again you can go
to patreon patreon comm slash dear Hank
and John you can also find lots of cool
stuff there I think we're gonna put
Molly Lewis's song about MySpace up
there as well as links to our myspace
profiles so that you can live what our
lives were like back in 2006 this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
our intern is Claudia Morales we get
lots of help with questions from
rosianna halse rojas our theme music is
by gunnarolla and as we say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]